The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: In this
session, we're
going to be looking at
carbohydrate biosynthesis.
Please look at Storyboard 29.
Looking at Panel A, the
next set of pathways
on which we're going
to focus concerns
carbohydrate biosynthesis.
First, we're going to look at
the pathway by which glycogen
is made.
As you know, glycogen is the
polymeric form of glucose
that's very readily available
for energy production.
The second pathway
is gluconeogenesis.
The organs that utilize
glucose as their metabolic fuel
prefer to have glucose at a
concentration of about 100
milligrams per
deciliter in the blood.
The challenge
comes from the fact
that we eat only sporadically,
and thus, levels of glucose
will go up and down
depending upon the time that
has passed since our last meal.
When glucose levels
drop, gluconeogenesis
is the pathway that's activated.
It takes non-carbohydrate
precursors,
converts them to glucose,
and then secretes the glucose
into the blood,
ultimately to help
maintain a constant
glucose concentration.
Looking at Panel
B, our first topic
is the synthesis of glycogen.
If you look back at my first two
lectures, I describe the
structure of glycogen,
which is also shown here.
The piece of glycogen
that I've shown
consists of a linear chain of
glucose molecules connected
together through
the 1 and 4 carbons.
Chemically, we call this
an alpha 1, 4 linkage.
To the left of the
glycogen molecule
is the non-reducing
end and to the right
is the reducing end, which is
connected by a tyrosine residue
to a protein called glycogenin.
Glycogenin is a variant of
the glycogen synthase enzyme
we'll talk about later.
Glycogenin has the
property that it
can synthesize a
polymeric glucose
chain, such as the
one shown, to boot up
the synthesis of glycogen.
In effect, glycogenin
forms a primer molecule
such as the one
shown that provides
a non-reducing end that can be
extended by its sister enzyme,
glycogen synthase.
While I've drawn
a linear glucose,
I want you to keep
in mind, the branches
off of the six carbon of
the glucoses in the chain
are possible.
As I mentioned earlier, glycogen
is designed for fast breakdown.
Its glucose units will quickly
enter the pathway of glycolysis
and generate ATPs in
a manner of seconds.
Let's now look at Panel
C. It's useful to review
the biochemical steps by
which glycogen is broken down
because the exact same
intermediates appear
in the reverse order in
the synthesis of glycogen.
The key enzyme for
glycogen breakdown,
or glycogenolysis, is
glycogen phosphorylase.
Glycogen phosphorylase
progressively will nip off
the non-reducing end--
that is the left-most
sugar as shown--
producing oxonium
ion intermediate.
And as we saw in
my first lecture,
glycogen phosphorylase
stereospecifically adds
inorganic phosphate
to the bottom face--
that is the alpha face
of the oxonium ion--
to give glucose 1-phosphate
with this stereochemistry shown.
Once again, these
same intermediates
are going to appear in
the synthesis of glycogen.
Now let's take a
look at the way that
glucose 1-phosphate interfaces
with the other biosynthetic
and catabolic pathways.
Let's look at Panel
D. This metabolic map
shows glycogen in the
lower right-hand corner.
We can see how glycogenolosis
results in glycogen breakdown
to glucose 1-phosphate, and
in the reverse direction,
we can see how glucose
1-phosphate can be used to make
glycogen by way of two enzymes--
UDP Glucose Pyrophosphorylase,
UGP, and Glycogen Synthase, GS.
Let's look a little
deeper at other pathways
with which glucose 1
phosphate interfaces.
This schematic shows
that glucose 1-phosphate
can be converted to
glucose 6-phosphate
by phosphoglucomutase, PGM.
In this case, the phosphate
is moved from the 1 carbon
to the 6 carbon of
the glucose moiety.
The opposite
reaction also occurs.
That is, if you have
glucose 6-phosphate,
phosphoglucomutase will convert
it to glucose 1-phosphate.
Glucose 6-phosphate is an
intermediate in glycolysis,
gluconeogenesis-- which is
the next pathway we're going
to look at--
and another future pathway,
the pentose phosphate pathway.
All of this shows us
that glucose 6-phosphate
is a crossroads and one of the
branches that leads from it
and it is by way of
glucose 1-phosphate.
Let's imagine a scenario
in which we eat a meal.
Glucose appears in
the blood as shown.
It is taken into the cell.
The enzymes hexokinase
or glucokinase
will phosphorylate the glucose
into glucose 6-phosphate.
If the glucose is not
needed for glycolysis
or the other pathways
that I mentioned,
phosphoglucomutase will
convert the glucose
6-phosphate to
glucose 1-phosphate,
and then in the pathway
of glycogen synthesis,
glucose 1-phosphate will be
polymerized into glycogen
for energy storage.
At this point, let's turn
to Storyboard 30 and look
at Panel A. Now
let's take a look
at the detail pathway by
which glucose 1-phosphate is
converted to
glycogen. At the left
is the structure of
glucose 1-phosphate.
The first enzyme involved is
UDP Glucose Pyrophosphorylase,
or UGP.
The second substrate
in this reaction
is UTP, uridine triphosphate.
The UDP Glucose
Pyrophosphorylase
catalyzes attack
by the phosphate
on the 1 carbon of
glucose 1-phosphate
on the alpha phosphorus of UTP.
The two products are
pyrophosphate and UDP glucose.
The reaction is made
thermodynamically irreversible
by hydrolysis of pyrophosphate
by inorganic pyrophosphatase
into two molecules of
inorganic phosphate.
The UDP glucose is the
substrate for the next enzyme
in the sequenced
glycogen synthase.
I'm going to divide
the glycogen synthase
reaction into two parts.
In the first, we see
cleavage of the bond
between the 1 carbon
of the glucose
and the beta
phosphate of the UDP.
This reaction liberates the UDP
and generates the oxonium ions
shown in the brackets.
Structurally, this oxonium
ion is the same intermediate
we saw in glycogen
breakdown, but here, we're
using it as a
biosynthetic reagent.
Let's look at Panel
B. In this panel,
we continue the glycogen
synthase reaction.
In Panel A, we generated
the oxonium ion
of glucose, which is shown here,
in Panel B in the lower left.
Glycogen synthase activates
the hydroxyl group
on the 4 carbon of the
terminal sugar residue.
That is the sugar on
the non-reducing end.
The oxygen on the non-reducing
sugar residue of glycogen
then attacks the bottom
face of the oxonium ion
to give rise to a glycogen
unit that has been extended
by one glucose residue.
I have put an asterisk
on the 6 carbon
of the glucose residue that's
been added to the growing
glycogen chain.